yeah that'll be my one self-indulging
statement yes I'm a damn hoop
s that was the green ball I'm a very
good driver I don't have my permit yet
but I will soon
so watch out New York I'm going to be
cruising the streets soon
hi I'm Chris Pratt here with Everwood
now is this your first Academy Award
the first thing that goes through my
mind is oh my God my father has to swear
to me he's gonna close his eyes when he
sees these Brad Pitt kids to the
screening to the premiere yesterday I
love Brad Pitt I'm stumbling I don't
know
Robert Downey Jr may have started it all
with the very first Iron Man movie in
2008 but we first met him in 1987. my
management and agent now like you know
you have to get more selective now when
I started out I was just like this B
film yeah B part I love it you know
I was just happy to be working he was
dating Sarah Jessica Parker and Justin
my actors are so insecure you know I
mean I I was thinking about it kept
saying oh I look so shiny in that ooh or
you know oh there was a lot of this oh
and sitting with people some people
enjoyed it or you know but then you
start wondering if your friends are just
gonna say yeah you're a killer
you know rdj's now worth a reported 300
million dollars thanks to his massive
Marvel success but he's not the only one
with an enviable end game
strike in my book Captain America AKA
Chris Evans is the sexiest man alive now
but he was the All-American jock in
2001's not another team movie he didn't
know it then but he was gearing up to be
a superhero
if I end up doing more movies with
stunts I think I'll probably invest in
some stunt classes you know I think it
must be learned it's not something you
can just win you can't just you know
have some courage and think you can get
away with it that is America's ass I was
emceeing bar mitzel receptions Ant-Man
Paul Rudd's Big Break was on the TV
series sisters in 1992 but at 23 he
didn't think he'd end up being one of
the seven Marvel stars named sexiest man
alive I don't think it ever will it
never has in my life and then I don't
think it'll happen though
Black Widow Scarlett Johansson was the
first actor to Executive produce her own
Marvel movie but when we met her she was
just 14 years old and telling us all
about learning to horseback ride for The
Horse Whisperer the first couple of
weeks I was in pain of course but other
than that I never really had any doubts
and I haven't fallen off yet knock
air knockhead
eternals Angelina Jolie was just another
10 year old on the Oscar red carpet with
her dad are you nervous for your dad
tonight I'm sorry
Angie's co-star Salma Hayek was sinking
her teeth into George Clooney on the
1995 setup From Dusk Till Dawn she told
us back then her parents weren't
thrilled when she moved to LA to follow
her dreams it's like why do you do this
you know just get married settle down we
want grandchildren I'm like no no I'm
going to Hollywood I'm going to try my
luck there I'm trying to keep it like
like I have a student who does movies on
the side you know not like
someone who does movies and does school
on the side you know because
um ultimately school is always more
important that's a 13 year old Natalie
Portman before she bulked up for Thor
and even though she turned into an
oscar-winning actress she kept her word
and graduated from Harvard
I need to act I need to be an actor for
this audition and this one I was like I
don't really know the lines um I'm just
like this character and they're like
perfect that's the guy we want right
there and yeah Star-Lord Chris Pratt
sounded a lot like his future
father-in-law when we first met him on
the Everwood set 20 years ago and all
that dancing we see in the Guardians
outtakes well he's been practicing those
moves since the very beginning a little
sample of some singing and dancing like
maybe a little Michael Jackson
questions
I know you're not going to play this I
can say whatever I want
[Music]